Magnus we've said pretty much everything
that can be said about this performance
the final thing is to hear it from the
man himself tell us about your emotions
right now yeah
yeah this is
just very very special to me uh I mean
I've had good days before in terms of
score
um I think I've even like I've
definitely played better but at some
point I realized
actually make it and I don't think I've
ever
like I've had stretches like in in
Poland where I had like 10 and a half
out of 11 or something but to win every
single game on one day I mean I have
ever done that before and probably won't
do again I think this is a record streak
in the grandchester almost for sure when
did you feel at what point did you start
dreaming about this
um
I guess when
when I had six out of six
um because I was thinking that well
other as a as black is a very difficult
matchup but you often get chances and I
thought like if I win that game I have a
very good very good chance
um so yeah I was definitely I mean
obviously it was like dreaming earlier a
little bit but that's the point where I
thought like yeah this could happen and
the UA Ali Reza talked about that moment
as well and he said that he did not
expect this move Queen A5 and he got
completely thrown off when he played
this move Queen A5 was that something
that prepared for him specifically or no
no it's like out of Europe it's actually
like a move because I I played
um I played Queen A5
um
I played Queen F5 in the opening against
him in in Miami in this position and I
was pretty badly and actually Aryan told
me about that F3 Queen M5 is is a move
so I thought I didn't really look at it
further but I thought yeah well let's uh
let's give it a try and it's always good
to
um to uh
to surprise your opponent in
and it definitely felt from the
beginning that there was some special
energy about your game you came into the
playing hole first round with some
shorts and then you went and changed
what's the story of uh that flower is in
your hair also we yeah we saw that some
flower had randomly stuck to my stuck to
my hair um so I was just following my
routine and I usually come back from
eating at about
like a quarter to uh three or ten to
three and now all of a sudden my key was
not working
um
yeah they wouldn't let me you know they
wouldn't let me in the room so I had to
go to reception but there was a long
line there so I realized like I'm not
gonna have time to get the key get
changed and everything so I just
just came to the game as was and changed
after Magnus this is another record
you're breaking you've broken many
before what do you usually do to
celebrate if anything I have I have a
big day tomorrow so I don't think I'll
be doing doing too much but um
you know this is yeah this is something
something out certainly remember like
one thing is
one thing is uh winning tournaments but
um yeah this feels really special
congratulations Magnus we'll see you
tomorrow thank you
thank you thank you Christian thank you
Magnus and here's his reaction magnus's
reaction to his perfect result of the
day winning every single game look at
him he's exalted I did it
[Laughter]
wow indeed pure joy